panel get that nice and hot sweet and
sour Peppers go brilliantly well there's
the center start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind pinky holding it down thumb
holding it nice and flat the flatter the
vegetables the more confident you are
when you slice so
red onion
olive oil in
I'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's term for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt and pepper add a tablespoon of
sugar sugar helps to break down the
peppers quicker but caramelize the
onions
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that's ready for the red wine
vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you see the sugar
it's worked as magic turn down the gas
and add a couple of tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now I want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds I want them off
[Music]
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops I want to make
sure they don't curl up in the pan they
start cutting up in the pan they're
going to cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the Rind means
the chop stays flat and Cooks evenly
Point The Knife Down
flip through it's seasoned beautifully
nice large shards of pepper punch that
through lightly guaranteed that
seasoning
is going to stay there hot pan touch
garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crushing
olive oil in just starting to smoke top
of the chop in
and lay away from me
it's nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork has stayed nice and
flat turn that over look at that
beautiful
I want a little bit of thyme underneath
the
start squeezing that garlic out I want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
till the pan and baste
so I'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time I'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color of that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side
beautiful
when they're that thick three and a half
to four minutes each size 30 seconds
from now they're going to be medium so
I'm going to take them out and let them
rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon
of these Peppers basil smells incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the pepper
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers and your conference is going to
shoot through the roof a stunning pork
chop with sweet and sour peppers
for the pork and porn balls in a bowl
add pork mince
then add finely chopped prawns
[Music]
diced Ginger
and chopped chives seasoned
and roll into ping pong sized balls
[Music]
for the broth heat fresh stock
and add star anise oyster sauce soy
sauce and sliced Ginger
gently simmer
fry the pork and prawn balls in a pan
until golden
then transfer to the bubbling broth
I have handfuls of spinach then serve
topped with finely sliced spring onions
a gorgeous healthy dish that uses Great
Value ingredients with amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat in under 20 minutes first
off get your roasting tray put the tray
on the gas pork ribs 60 meat and 35 40
fat give them a really good season salt
and pepper nice thing about this cup
they stay incredibly moist when they're
on the bone and the longer you cook them
the more delicious they become just push
all that seasoning in make sure that
tray is nice and hot
and I really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
Ginger place it down nice and firmly and
slice
garlic
and it's really important before you add
anything those ribs make sure you've got
the color and the ribs first don't rush
it
turn them over that's what I want right
ginger and garlic in spread it around on
all those ribs to sort of roast the
ginger and the garlic chili flakes chili
flakes in next Szechuan pepper citrusy
vibrant peppercorns incredible in
next star anise and some fresh honey so
look what's happening color on the ribs
is extraordinary soy sauce brings that
little bit of sort of saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
Japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of tartness
to the ribs if you can't find rice wine
a dry sherry is a great substitute 300
mil
takes out the heat of that Szechuan
pepper those dry chili flakes make sure
they're all laid down like a nice tight
box of matches bring that up to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with a combination of flavors
[Music]
slacking a little touch of vinegar
on that sharpness now I think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel the color on the ribs is amazing
I want a bit of a sort of oniony flavor
I'll put some spring onions in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree they
give a sharpness the final taste of that
pork
and then my spring onions
and with my stock
400 mL of stock
this is just a simple chicken stock the
stock just sits underneath the ribs it
absorbs into the rib and the top of the
rib glazes underneath the rib that gets
crispy and Rich and that's what makes
the ribs nice and moist really important
into the oven
[Music]
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now
wow they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted Edge becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth I want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of the way that we
finish them in the restaurant but every
minute
they glaze in that tray they just get to
taste better and better
now look at them
I'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want you can put them in the
fridge and the flavor will keep
developing then just reheat them when
you want to serve
so
a piece rib has a nice slice of Ginger
on there
[Music]
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
my next easy
dishing The Versatile noodle is
stir-fried pork noodles
[Music]
marinade pork mince and shaoxing rice
wine I fortified Chinese wine
soy sauce and sesame oil
next five chopped ginger in hot olive
oil
and garlic
next add Szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
and brown
if you want more seasoning add extra soy
sauce
then add fiery chili bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
adding cooked egg noodles
mixed together
finally topped with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
[Music]